[Musique]
en cinq mandats il a navigué dans cinq
groupes politiques différents sans pour
autant renier ses valeurs mon invité est
engagé au centre depuis presque 50 ans
un centriste un peu rebelle voire
insoumis vous allez
[Musique]
voir bonjour Yannick favenek Beco
bonjour alors dans les années 70 un
lycéen qui s'intéressait un peu à à la
politique était encore souvent attiré
par une figure comme t Gevara euh vous
votre Che Gevara il avait pas les
cheveux longs il était chauve il parlait
avec un un phrasé un peu en poulet
c'était Valéri Giscard destin pour lui
vous étiez prêt à tout jusqu'à vous
faire exclure de votre lycée
racontez-nous oui oui c'est vrai que je
me suis engagé j'avais 16 ans j'étais au
lycée j'étais d'ailleurs dans un lycée
euh
entouré par beaucoup de gens de de
gauche et moi j'étais pourtant venu d'un
milieu modeste j'étais le seul giscardo
giscardien et effectivement j'ai fait la
campagne du président giscardestin du
candidat giscardestin en
1974 j'étais un peu seul au lycée mais
je l'ai fait et je peux vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui je ne le regrette
absolument pas et et vous vous êtes fait
exclure du lycée parce que vous avez de
l'internat oui parce que j'ai voilà
j'avais imité le la signature de ma
grand-mère pour m'autoriser à sortir
pour aller assister à un meeting du
président giscardestin du candidat
giscardestin à Nantes et évidemment
comme je suis un mauvais imitateur en
tous les cas en écriture benah je me
suis fait choper et je me suis fait
virer de de l'internat alors vous êtes
donc passionné pour giscar pour ses
idées pour ses valeurs vous avez même
créé et présider l'antenne locale des
jeunes giscardiens à saint-nazer
saint-nazer faut savoir que c'est quand
même une ville qui est profondément
ancrée à gauche depuis l'éternité
qu'est-ce qui dans la figure de giscar a
pu susciter un tel enthousiasme chez le
jeune homme de 16 ans alors 18 ans je
crois sur la la photo qu'on voit mais 16
ans au moment de la campagne
présidentielle bah d'abord parce que
giscar c'était la modernité on on
sortait des années de Gaulle Pompidou en
fait pour moi giscar il a fait passer la
5e République du noir et blanc à la
couleur donc c'était la modernité et
puis c'était le seul candidat qui
s'adressait à la jeunesse avec des idées
modernes
avec projet de réforme avec des projets
de réforme qu'il a réalisé lui c'est pas
uniquement un programme comme ça puis
ensuite on passe à autre chose il a
réalisé son projet des réformes
effectivement comme l'abaissement de la
majorité de 21 à 18 ans entre autres
mais aussi l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse mais aussi le déorce par
consentement mutuel bref beaucoup de
réformes de société qui aujourd'hui
encore marque notre notre pays alors
cette passion giscar elle s'est pas
éteinte avec le temps euh vous on vous a
vu le recevoir dans votre
circonscription C en 2016 pour célébrer
les 40 ans de son élection
ouais
ouzmeère
voitétait je CIS vousvezit votre
dernière campagne législative au volant
de la Smart de Valérie Giscard destin
quand on voit ça c'est ça va au-delà de
la politique là vous êtes un pur fan oui
mais vous savez je crois que c'est
important d'avoir des repères quand on
fait de la politique et je trouvais que
c'étaitah là aussi une marque de
d'affection et d'attachement au
président Giscard destin que de racheter
sa dernière voiture al c'est gisc qui
est de votre engagement dans la famille
centriste mais c'est François Léotard
qui vous a mis le le pied à l'étrier
c'est ça oui en tous les cas je crois
que ma collaboration avec François
Léotard comme assistant parlementaire et
puis aussi à son cabinet lorsqu'il était
ministre de la Culture et de la
Communication ça a été pour moi le vrai
démarrage de ma vie politique parce que
j'étais d'abord en province je faisais
de la politique en province et là
j'arrivais à Paris un peu comme
Rastignac j'allais dire bah à nous deux
Paris à nous deux la politique et je
dois beaucoup à Françis Léotard parce
que que il m'a mis le pied à l'étrier il
m'a appris énormément de choses et j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup d'affection pour
François Léotard alors vous êtes attaché
aux valeurs centristes mais visiblement
un peu moins attaché au partis ou au
groupes politiques de l'Assemblée depuis
votre première élection en 2002 vous
avez appartenu successivement au groupe
UMP udi modem liberté et territoire à
nouveau udi aujourd'hui horizon le le
parti d'Édouard Philippe vous avez un
peu la bougeotte non pas du tout moi mes
valeurs elles sont toujours les même
libéral social européen humaniste
maintenant les partis politiques eux ils
ont beaucoup changé en en 30 ou 40 ans
euh ils ont changé d'alliance ils ont
changé de nom voilà mais moi j'ai pas
changé et vous savez les groupes
parlementaires les groupes
parlementaires ce sont des outils pour
travailler à l'Assemblée nationale mais
ce ne sont pas forcément des des des des
ancrages de de conviction mes
convictions sont les mêmes je suis resté
au centre droit et je ne varierai pas de
cet ancrage et en basculant dans la
majorité présidentielle tout de même sur
la dernière législtive oui parce que en
fait je me disais que en en 2022 entre
Marine Le Pen et Emmanuel Macron pour
moi il y avait pas de d'option possible
c'était Emmanuel Macron je suis dans la
majorité présidentielle je suis loyal
mais je suis libre ah ben écoutez vous
me tendez une perche parce que j'allais
vous parler de votre compte Twitter vous
affichez ce qui ressemble un peu à une
devise justement loyale mais libre je me
mets dans la tête d'un d'un président de
groupe à l'assemblée qui vous voit
toquer à sa porte en voyant ça il doit
se dire Yannick favnek loyal mais libre
doit pas être très fiable toi mais je ne
dois de compte qu'à mes électeurs je ne
dois de compte qu'à C et ceux qui depuis
presque 25 ans 5 mandat dont le dernier
je rappelle que j'étais le seul député
de la majorité élu ou réélu dès le
premier tour je le dois des comptes qu'à
ceux qui m'ont fait confiance oui mais
voilà quand vous dites ça et mettez-vous
à la place d'un président de groupe il
dit bah lui quand quand tu un peu de
tempête je pas pouir compter sur lui je
vous dis ça parce que non non non quand
il a de la tempête je je suis fidèle à
mes convictions tout simpleement vous
voyez à quoi je fais référence non la
réforme des retraites oui quand dans le
Figaro vous annoncez publiquement que
vous voterez contre la réforme des
retraites alors que vous êtes dans le
groupe je n'ai jamais dévié de mes
convictions ma campagne législative je
l'ai fait en partie sur effectivement la
nécessité de faire une réforme des
retraites mais non pas en faisant de
l'âge le totem de la réforme mais en
disant il faut prendre en compte le
nombre de trimestres mais je vous n' pas
défend vot n'ai pas changé rapport à
ça fait payer ça en
interne le silenceok le silence Joker
oui on me l'a fait payer bien sûr qu'on
me le fait payer on me le fait encore
payer aujourd'hui peu importe moi j'ai
des convictions je reste fidèle à mes
convictions alors on vous l'a fait payer
visiblement vos électeurs eux non hein
vous l'avez dit euh vous avez été réélu
cinq fois d'affilé trois fois sur vos
cinq victoires élu au au premier tour
oui euh quand vous dites que vous ne
devez votre élection qu'à vos électeurs
est-ce que c'est pas un peu prétentieux
quand même bah je sais pas si je suis
élu c'est parce
que oui évidemment mais vous avez une
investiture le soutien d'un parti
politique sincèrement moi je suis élu ou
réélu sur mon nom ouais sur ce que je
défends c'est sur votre encrage
territorial c'est-à-dire vous êtes c'est
mon encrage territorial absolument c'est
le fait que je suis présent sur le
terrain du lundi matin au dimanche soir
ou presque parce qu'il bien sûr le mardi
mercredi le jeudi qui réservé au travail
ici à l'Assemblée mais je suis en
permanence présent sur le terrain et
c'est ça aussi je crois que les
électeurs me reconnaissent alors on va
justement revoir un extrait d'un d'un
reportage tourné par ma ma collègue maïé
Frémont qui vous avez suivi sur le
terrain dans ce combat que vous menez
pour votre territoire et plus
globalement tout le département de la
Mayenne qui est très concerné par la
problématique pour les français pour 87
% du territoire national qui est un
désert médical voilà qui est très
concerné par cette problématique des
déserts médicaux absument bonjour je
suis Guillaume Garo je suis député de la
première circonscription de la Mayenne
bonjour je suis Yannick favenek député
de la 3e circonscription de la Mayenne
et ensemble nous nous battons contre les
déserts médicaux alors à tout de suite à
tout de suite alors j'ai choisi cet
extrras c'est le tout début du reportage
circo sur LCP que vous pouvez revoir sur
notre chaîne YouTube j'ai choisi cet
extrait parce que bah Guillaume Garot
vous l'avez dit il est pas de votre bord
politique et lui il est député
socialiste et vous partagez ensemble ce
même combat pour votre territoire c'est
veut dire que quand on défend son
territoire la notion de droite de gauche
ça a plus vraiment lieu d'être l'accès
aux soins c'est pas de gauche c'est pas
de droite c'est l'intérêt généralière
chose prière chose les les réponses
elles sont dans l'intérêt général et
puis je vais vous dire une chose les
Français l'an dernier ils n'ont pas
donné de majorité absolue au président
de la République ils ont dit
débrouillez-vous majorité relative
apprenez à travailler ensemble apprenez
à coconstruire ensemble parlez-vous
enfin et ben avec Guillaume Garot c'est
exactement ce que l'on fait dans notre
département de la Mayenne et je peux
vous dire une chose c'est que les
Mayennais apprécient beaucoup notre
collaboration parce qu'ils savent qu'on
a un objectif c'est d'essayer de faire
en sorte que l'accès aux soins se fasse
de façon plus égale sur l'ensemble du
territoire national et notamment en
Mayenne qui malheureusement est un des
trois départements de France les plus
impacté par cette difficulté d'avoir un
médecin alors avant de passer à notre
quiz je voulais revenir sur un épisode
de votre vie politique qui vous a blessé
personnellement pendant des années votre
femme a été une de vos collaboratrices
parlementaires à l'assemblé je suis très
fier qu'elle l' été parce que elle
travaillait et je peux vous dire que les
maénis s'en souviennent on va en parler
vous avez dû la licencier à la suite de
l'affaire Fillon pour respecter la loi
sur la moralisation de la vie publique
euh aujourd'hui vous dites que cette loi
c'est une mauvaise loi ou est-ce que
vous vous dites que c'est le prix à
payer pour éviter les abus réels qui ont
pu exister peut-être euh je pense
qu'effectivement euh beaucoup parce
qu'elle était pas la seule he mon épouse
a être engagée par son mari en tous les
cas travaillant avec un un parent euh je
pense que on a payé pour ce qu'une
minorité a fait ou n'a pas fait
justement et mon épouse elle a des
compétences et je suis très fier qu'elle
ait collaboré avec moi pendant toutes
ces années et je regrette
qu'effectivement euh pour une minorité
qui a mal agi une majorité qui
travaillait et bien se retrouve pénalisé
ou s'est retrouvé pénalisé il y a 6 ans
de ça maintenant on passe à notre quiz à
présent si vous le voulez bien euh je
vous rappelle le principe je vais
commencer des phrases et vous allez
devoir les compléter on y va si giscar
avait présidé la France
aujourd'hui la France irait certainement
beaucoup mieux d'abord les réformes
elles auraient été faites ensuite on
aurait certainement c'est c'est un coup
porté à Emmanuel Macron B je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on est incapable de
réformer ce pays je dis pas que c'est la
faute du président de la République hein
je crois que le peuple français aussi
probablement beaucoup changé mais oui je
crois que la France serait entrée encore
plus fortement dans la modernité dans le
21e siècle et que les réformes auraient
été faites après plus de 20 ans à
l'Assemblée je me dis
parfois je me dis parfois que bah que ça
a beaucoup changé qu'est-ce qui a le
plus changé pour vous ah je pense qu'on
est on est passé on est passé dans un
autre mode de fonctionnement d'abord il
y a il y a pas de respect il y a plus de
il y a plus certaines valeurs qui
existaient il y a il y a un peu plus de
20 ans quand j'ai été élu pour la
première fois je le regrette parce que
je crois que c'est important que nous
ayons une l'Assemblée nationale qui est
quand même le temple de la démocratie
qui fonctionne dans de meilleures
conditions que c'est le cas aujourd'hui
enfin ma plus grande satisfaction en
tant que député ah la plus grande
satisfaction c'est ah il y a il y a
tellement de choses que je pourrais vous
dire euh tiens par exemple cette semaine
est entrée en vigueur une proposition de
loi pour laquelle je me suis battu
beaucoup battu avec d'autres c'est la
déconjugalisation de la loocation adules
handicapé très important très attendu
par les personnes concernées ça montre
quoi ça montre on peut agir concrètement
quand on fait de la politique pour le
quotidien et pour le bien des gens une
dernière question on plus de 20 ans à
l'Assemblée vous n'avez pas réussi à
faire adopter une seule proposition de
loi à votre
nom est-ce que c'est pas le prix de
votre liberté de votre indépendance
revendiquée d'abord je vous parlais tout
à l'heure de la location adulte
handicapé j'ai beaucoup contribué avec
d'autres mais j'ai beaucoup contribué et
puis vous savez laisser sa trace sur une
proposition de loi c'est pas forcément
un but en soi d'abord parce qu'on peut
faire avancer les choses par le BIA des
amendements qu'on peut faire adopter
dieu merci et puis il y a tellement de
loi dans notre pays que finalement avoir
une loi au nom de de faven BCO je suis
pas convaincu que ce soit en toutous les
cas c pas mon objectif numéro 1 mon
objectif numéro 1 c'est d'être vraiment
au plus près des préoccupations de mes
concitoyens merci beaucoup Yanni d'être
venu dans la politique et moi merci à
[Musique]
vous